what is happening there cat hello cat how
you doing there copper what's going on there
reject nation greg here thank you so much for
clicking on this video with the batman now out
in cinemas i wanted to talk today about
every upcoming batman project confirmed
or rumored between 2022-2025 that's right gregor
the title of a recent cause with wonder video
replaced the word marvel with batman and came
up with a whole video based around that and
you know what if you are a part of the camp that
subscribes to the idea there's way too much batman
out there well guess what we're getting even way
more like some of these are rumored and a good
amount of these are confirmed so if you can leave
a like and let's just swing on into action people
so first on the list is the batman dose there
will be no spoilers for the batman here today
but before this movie even came out matt reeves
did say that they have been in early development
on the sequel the producer recently talking at
a red carpet event i think it was actually the
premiere he did say that even though this one
was pretty much a five year long process that
the batman part two would take nowhere near
as long to get off the ground so we should
probably expect the batman two within about three
years unless that producer's just being a dick
and he's gonna release it like on four years
and 11 months which would be annoying however
we don't know any details about this one yet the
studios want us to stay solely focused on the
batman part one we've heard talks about maybe they
could get joker in here which sounds predictable
and generic as much as i want to see joker in this
universe matt reeves explored the idea of trying
to bring like a realistic mr freeze to life which
i just think would be so much cooler and obviously
this is an early stage in the career of penguin
we know he's getting a spin-off so maybe penguin
could be the villain in it question goes to you
guys who would you want to be the villain of the
batman part two moving on we might as well stay
on topic and stay in the matt reeves of bataversy
thingy that's going on we have either two or
three shows confirmed maybe another one here
the reason i say that number is because there was
something that came out recently that matt reeves
said where he did say we're doing another series
that connects to arkham asylum i didn't know
what that might mean because the way how this
is phrased okay well we have two confirmed shows
right now another rumored show would this arkham
asylum thing be connected to one of the shows or
would it be its own separate entity regardless to
explore more of arkham asylum inside of the world
matt reeves has helped create would be awesome
this would be something that feels probably more
unsettling grim you know realistic what you've
seen in the batman trailers vms in the batman
movie you only get like a taste of it in the
batman film but you do get an idea of like i
would hate to walk through the halls of this place
which i think would be a fantastic show maybe you
can actually get dr hugo strange involved but
if not doing just like an arkham asylum based
show i think the one where arkham will make the
most sense would probably be for one that was the
first confirmed series gotham pd i think that's
just a working title right now so it's where the
batman takes place in year two of him being batman
the plot synopsis that we have so far for this
is the series is set during batman's first year
of operations and focus on corruption in gotham
city according to various reports in a showcase
of dc fandom the series will focus on a corrupt
gcpd officer in the battle for his soul now
there have been reports that jeffrey wright
will reprise his role as james gordon for this
series you know if like you've seen the gotham
show like myself that was on fox you might go
well this might be exactly the same thing when
you watch the movie it's obviously very different
and whereas the movie does take inspiration from
the comic book year one it's not like a direct
adaptation of it i think for this show it could
be way more of an adaptation of batman year one
as much as i wanted to do its own thing and not
be reliant on a batman appearance i think this
show would totally work with a batman appearance i
kind of sound like seth rory this would make the
most sense especially because it's taking place
during batman year one and in that comic book
which both batman begins and the batman draw
inspiration from it's gordon who's really the
main character of that comic book and i always
thought it would be cool if they did some type of
perspective shift where maybe sometimes you see
bruce wayne and sometimes you see batman but the
show never goes out of its way to go they're one
in the same just keep it locked into like the cops
or gordon's perspective and with the movie dealing
so much with corruption in the gcpd i think this
would be also a great opportunity to set up more
of the crime families that are established as well
things like the falcone family the moroni family
other families that aren't coming to mind right
now so next on the list three four i don't
remember catwoman matt reeves did say that there
have been discussions about zoe kravitz having
her own hbo max show as well or having her own
spin-off series in some capacity and this would
be cool and also for that i want to talk about the
penguin series which is actually confirmed matt
reeves even recently said we're doing this penguin
series and one of the great things about that is
it's colin farrell he's like you've never seen him
he's so incredible and he's a scene stealer and
he really is along the way we thought maybe we
could do his character as a series so i talked
to hbo max and showed them colin in the movie
and spoke to them about what this could be and
they said let's do it we'll do all your all the
batman you want matt reeves will do it yeah i'm
excited for the series dude and i know this is a
completely different thing even james gunn taking
peacemaker turning that into an hbo max there was
a character that i was like i don't really want
to see a show about peacemaker i ended up loving
the hell out of it and this would be something
entirely different but led by colin farrell
and it's penguin i'm really awesome and the
reason i'm sort of combining catwoman and penguin
because i think the same can be said about both
maybe more for penguin i would say than catwoman
this show could do either a prequel that lead into
the events of the batman or it could be a sequel
things that happen after the batman that's what
a prequel and a sequel are in case you didn't know
or maybe they can like better call solid where you
know usually i see the past and then you also see
the future either way it sounds like penguin will
be a story that will be fed in between the batman
and the batman too and i'm really hoping they
bring the events from penguin into the batman too
all right i think i think that's it from madrid's
batman world it's getting to the point where
he's gonna say hey i like that background actor
give him a show so next upcoming this year is the
flash which is really just a bat verse movie no i
don't know i i actually um the more i hear about
this film sorry to sound like it really will still
be a flash movie ultimately where batman's are
supporting batman but yeah we know about this ben
affleck set to appear in here his final appearance
he's made pretty clear he wants it to be his final
performance i'll add and michael keaton as well
who's set to return we already know let's move
on bad girl now not to be an hbo max show but an
hbo max movie which will take place in the more
established still pretty confusing dc eu timeline
whatever it's going to be we gotta wait for the
flash apparently to understand what this movie's
gonna really be because gordon will be there who
was introduced in justice league it's gonna be
michael keaton continuing on as batman and he
seems to be really jazzed about it i don't know if
it's him or his publicist who's putting out photos
of the bat suit on social media probably his
publicist don't really see michael keaton
sitting around being like this is the right photo
on the right filter for that you know i don't see
him doing that there's rumors of robin appearing
in here as well and and batgirl of course batgirl
barbara gore finally getting her own thing but
speaking of justice league and confusing timelines
i do believe in the powers of the multiverse
this is being really demanded and after we got
zack snyder's justice league a film that many many
many thought would never see the light of day and
this is a much bigger prospect to handle zack
snyder's justice league two and three i really
want to touch on like the ben affleck side of
things do i believe that there's a possibility he
could come back if they ended up getting us off
the ground sure uh but let's just focus on the
fact that zack snyder's justice league two and
three could continue many of you have probably
already heard by now there's that warner media
discovery merger happening and we're discovery ceo
david zaslov he's gonna be taking over the
organization there are insiders that reveal that
people like warner brothers chairman ann sarnoff
dc films president walter hamada warner brothers
pictures group toby emmerich are not expected to
remain three people who are easily zack snyder's
closest friends and apparently there's another
insider that leaked this of course the leaks were
taken with a grain of salt that zaslov is focused
on producing more content that audiences seek
especially warner media's most popular ips and
reportedly in the year of 2021 when so many movies
had the option to be streamed and a lot of movies
that should have just been the theaters went to
streaming zack snyder's justice league i believe
was in the top three of most stream movies of 2021
so this can present a good opportunity hell yeah
multiverse it off let's get zack snyder's justice
league two and three i love the batman i'm very
curious about the flash also still really won zack
snyder's justice league two and three another
one that has not been wiped off the table here
one that i really wanted nightwing person i
believe wrote in his attach to direct this movie
is chris mckay from the lego batman movie and he
said in mid-2021 so this is fairly recent when we
talked about it is that it's a movie that i still
really want to do i love the character of dick
grayson as a young adult becoming his own kind of
superhero character that was going to be a father
and son story and also a revenge movie sounds
very much like the lego batman movie which i was
really excited about because there's a lot going
on on that script it was going to be really primal
and paired down on like a real red meat movie
in the best way i'm batman i love that world
that probably has such a fun movie but there was
a period in my life when i was really young when
i read a lot of comics and that actually came from
getting introduced into nightwing so nightwing is
the character i've wanted to see most brought to
the big screen i don't watch titan so i think he's
in there if i'm not mistaken but to see him in
live action form there's so many actors who could
play dick grayson and at that stage in his life
it's a really interesting character so maybe with
batgirl we could get the introduction to robin and
whoever's cast is robin could be spinned off into
nightwing the first comics i think i ever actually
read was the hunt for oracle and that's like the
beginnings of when dick grayson moonlights
as a cop and he moonlights as a vigilante
what's he moonlighting ass takes place in
bloodhaven has the villain blockbuster of
course barbara gordon's oracle although be very
confusing timeline because you know like she has
to be batgirl for a while before she can be oracle
who is like paralyzed and [ __ ] so um just do its
own nightwing movie make the chris mckay one
all right who didn't see this one coming the
movie that made a billion dollars won some oscars
joker 2. now not much has known about this movie
it's been reported that the first draft has at
least been submitted they got the first draft say
sometimes i just laugh way too hard on my own dumb
jokes there's rumors about lady gaga being courted
for this we did our own video where we were sort
of pitching like what we think the plot of this
film could be recommend you guys go check that
out i actually really love that video joker 2
it's coming don't be surprised why would you
be surprised all right and then speaking of
nightwing from earlier this one i really want
this one i really do i'm gonna preface it with
this it doesn't seem likely at the moment but you
never know crazier [ __ ] has happened the lego
batman movie two so the reason why this might not
happen is because while the lego batman movie is
beloved like a lot of batman fans usually consider
that one of the top five best batman movies it's
beloved made a good amount of money but the lego
movie two did not do that well lego ninjago movie
didn't do that well and i believe the rights have
been bought or reverted something either way they
used to be with warner brothers who obviously does
the dc [ __ ] and now the rights of the lego movie
franchise are over at universal and i don't think
universal's really interested in doing this and
no reports are indicating that they would be
interested in doing it they probably just want
to do their own thing make it lego fast and
furious or some [ __ ] which actually wouldn't
be a bad idea chris mckay had this to say recently
dan harmon from rick and morty and michael waldron
of rick and morty and also loki and dr strange
multiverse madness had done a first draft of the
script that was really great it was truly epic
both from an action standpoint and from a story
standpoint the structure was godfather part two
he kisses robin on the cheek and says i knew who
was you dick a story about batman's relationship
to the justice league and superman that was well
as the formative moments of the justice league and
batman's relationship with superman then like this
just sounded like a truly heartfelt movie you
know i think that's something that was really
interesting about the first film was that it
starts off just super funny like it is hilarious
and cool but mainly hilarious and then it just
has such depth to it by the end and i loved how
when talking about this he mainly spoke about
wanting to explore the development of batman as
a character his relationships learning how to form
connections cutting between times that just sounds
awesome and i feel like a lot of people really
love this to happen alright another animated movie
here that will have batman dc league of super
pets so there's a trailer that came out for this
did not see it honestly i actually haven't i could
just watch it on my own i don't need to have a
camera pointer on me for every trailer i watch
anyway the part of it is this when the justice
league is captured by lex luthor superman's
dog krypto forms a team of shelter pets who
were given super powers how named ace who becomes
super strong and indestructible a pig named pb
who can grow to giant size a turtle named merton
who becomes super fast and a squirrel named chip
who gains electric powers and batman's gonna be in
here somewhere moving on batman caped crusader you
thought the mad reeve [ __ ] was done well it kind
of is but it's kind of not because he's one of
the producers of this so matt reeves jj abrams and
bruce tim are revealed to be producing this series
jj abrams who uh whose films are loved by everyone
equally described it as a thrilling cinematic and
evocative of batman's noir roots while diving
deeper into the psychology of these iconic
characters and have bruce tim involved in this
sounds amazing and i think jj abrams there's
a lot of his films i actually do really love i
think he's a better producer generally than he
is a director to have him involved on the creative
side and that department i think is awesome and
of course with matt reeves this honestly sounds
like this could shape up to be like an amazing ass
animated series like this really does sound
like this could be something super special and
it's going to be released on hbo max and cartoon
network all right people the last one i got today
check this out if you thought cars that franchise
was cool well have you heard of bat wheels bat
wheels is an upcoming american animated superhero
preschool series starring crime fighting vehicles
alongside dc superheroes will be on cartoon
network and hbo max so in this show the bat
wheels are reported to be sentient super powered
crime fighting vehicles that fight alongside
our heroes batman robin batgirl and a host of dc
superheroes they're gonna have been created by the
bat computer and the heroes are essentially gonna
be like kids with little to no life experience
it's gonna be like cars but would like batman
and guess who's voicing batman this one actually
genuinely surprised the [ __ ] out of me it was
batman's gonna be voiced by ethan hawk moon knight
now bat wheels he's dominating the comic sphere
man anyway was there one here that i missed i
know we didn't talk about any upcoming dc
animated movies that are like based on like
a comic run or something or the video games
but what i leave off the list which one here
are you most excited for thanks for joining
me on this journey i'll catch y'all soon